combien ski national park is just
outside the Polish capital Warsaw here
you can find a house that looks like
it's made of timber but the facade is
actually made of concrete
gw1 welcome and please get inside my
house 600 tons of concrete went into the
house which is owned by banker piatra
mayakovsky the goal was to make the
house look natural in in this location
because the location is surrounded with
pine wood and we didn't want to be you
know intruders or invaders into this
place we wanted to be at home
concrete plays a major role in the
interior as well the wood like
appearance of the walls gives this
normally harsh and cold material an
entirely different feel
it's not cold at all you can touch it
you know it really feels good you know
and then if you look at the structure
since it really resembles what and it
really still has contains some wooden
parts it is not cold at all I think I
feel you know this is a very warm
material paradox alley milk offski moved
into the 450 square meter house with his
wife and three children some eight years
ago at first he had some doubts about
the use of concrete but not anymore
we can feel that this place probably
will outlive most of us easily and
that's why you know it it it it brings
some sort of stability also so I like it
yes stability comes at a price though
you can't simply hammer a nail into a
concrete ball and hang a picture for
example but milk offski has a simple
trick
[Music]
this is one of the versions of the
double-sided sticker this one goes like
you know sometimes when you can you have
that shoe fixing like this so just take
away one part yes stick it to the wall
and the other part we'll stick it to the
picture I need to just about one against
the other and that's it very simple
the mayakovsky family enjoys being close
to nature the house has a rooftop
terrace and stands on 600 square metres
of land the inner courtyard has a pool
planning and building lasted three years
it took time to develop the perfect
texture and color to achieve the
illusion of wood on the concrete surface
we're experimenting quite a lot and we
were happy to find people who are
enthusiastic about working with with
concrete so we found a Danish provider
of the cement and a company from Krakow
that is a historic city in south of
Poland that brought the ingredients
natural rock that is used to renovate
the facades of the medieval buildings in
Krakow and this is how the mixture was
created
a house that has a warm and natural feel
proof that concrete is more versatile
than it may appear you just have to be
prepared to experiment
[Music]